puisque vous êtes tous les deux fans de
foot évidemment vous avez j'imagine
regardez ce match des Bleus il y a un
mot d'abord sur ce match finalement
perdu on va revenir sur la confusion qui
a eu en fin de match qu'est-ce que vous
avez pensé de ce matin souligne
il y a plusieurs regards à avoir le
regard du du sur le jeu ça nous a donné
un enseignement c'est que
il y a en France largement de quoi faire
deux équipes et donc
mais pas trois et donc quand on a autant
de blessés
décisif comme Pogba Kanté Benzema etc et
bien la profondeur du banc se réduit et
hier c'était assez lamentable le jeu
fourni en première mi-temps pas fallu
faire pardon autant de changements de la
part de Didier parce que j'ai pas envie
de juger parce que le technicien il sait
si par exemple un justement comme il y a
peu de profondeur si un des
indispensables avait été blessés parce
qu'on l'avait fait jouer on sera en
train de dire café des champs donc moi
je vais pas voilà on peut toujours
refaire les choses après l'essentiel
c'est qu'il y a pas de blessés qu'il y a
pas de carton que donc type peut être
opérationnel dans les moments décisifs
notamment le 8e de finale mais voilà on
a pu constater l'enseignement d'hier
c'est que
on y va alors et on n'a pas intérêt à
avoir des blessés plus tard après j'ai
un deuxième commentaire à faire qui est
là sur sur quelque chose très symbolique
qui
est sur le but de Griezmann c'est ça on
va en parler sur la coupure on va
évidemment parler mais on va quand même
faire réagir
évidemment qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé
vous de ce match je voudrais dire que
c'est des parmi les différences qu'on a
un point de convergence c'est la passion
du foot avec avec David insuline je
crois j'ai pas eu la chance de pouvoir
le regarder parce que j'étais en
hémicycle il y a après-midi moi et j'ai
une question d'ailleurs j'aurais mon
Gonnet peut poser la question est-ce
qu'il faut pas suspendre le travail
parlementaire quand il y a des matchs de
l'équipe nationale
ça existe dans certains pays alors en
Italie notamment mais c'est pas qualifié
cette année donc
les crédits relatifs aux collectivités
territoriales je vais notamment des
amendements à défendre donc je crois que
j'ai pas rater grand chose en fait ce
qu'on me dit j'ai pas rater grand chose
de ce match moi aussi sans juger je peux
dire quand même que 9 changements
d'emblée on sait que ce troisième match
et quand on a la chance de se qualifier
des deux premiers matchs est très bien
fait l'équipe de France en étant
d'ailleurs chahuté sur ces deux proches
elle a eu elle a eu la capacité de se
qualifier tout de suite et donc on sait
bien que ce troisième match est un match
pour faire jouer les coiffeurs comme on
dit tourner l'effectif mais non il a eu
raison de gérer oui mais neuf d'un coup
c'est on voit bien d'ailleurs à la fin
on est obligé de faire rentrer quelques
quelques cadors pour pour essayer
d'inverser la tendance peut-être qu'il y
avait un équilibre à trouver en faisant
à moitié-moitié et est-ce qu'on sait que
la profondeur du pont n'est pas là on a
eu beaucoup de blessés on a une attaque
de feu mais on a quasiment pas de milieu
de terrain et en défense ils sont tous
pas à leur place quoi donc c'est un peu
compliqué de jouer et je voudrais dire
qu'il faut toujours aussi respecter moi
je me félicite que ça n'est pas
la Tunisie on le voyait était très très
allante pour gagner ce match et je me
félicite que ça n'est pas faussé l'issue
des qualifications pour les huitièmes de
finale puisque même en concédant cette
défaite aller à la Tunisie la France des
qualifiée et la Tunisie n'est pas
qualifiée donc ça n'a pas faussé le jeu
on va revenir sur ce qui s'est passé on
va écouter d'autres supporters que vous
puisque Gaspard flamand est allé en
rencontrer hier voir ce qu'ils ont pensé
de ce match on les écoute
on a vu qu'il y avait quand même une
petite différence de niveau entre le
début et la fin du match quand il y a
les titulaires sur le terrain ou quand
ils sont sur le sur le banc je pense que
c'est de bonne augure pour la suite le
match était pas de très très bonne
qualité mais
tout le monde va arriver en forme pour
les 8e et c'est ça qui compte alors j'ai
pas vu je l'ai pas vu en entier mais on
m'avait prévenu que bon c'était un peu
décevant ce soir et là par contre le on
avait marqué et au final on n'a pas
marqué oui là c'est très élevant ouais
je confirme parce que je sais que
derrière là il a il a économisé tous les
joueurs tous les jours de l'équipage en
gros enfin tous les joueurs qui sont
titulaires depuis le début les
économiser on était qualifiés on le
savait c'est pas moi je suis confiant
pour la suite ça va on va la gagner
cette coupe du monde cette confiance
moins confiance parce que je sais très
bien ce que c'est que une coupe du monde
on l'a gagné des fois avec des concours
de circonstances qui auraient pu
basculer à la dernière minute sur autre
chose je connais trop le foot pour
savoir que on a une équipe solide qui
peut aller au bout mais que sur un match
à partir de maintenant c'est sur un
match que ça se joue il peut y avoir
tellement de choses qui se passent et il
y a quatre cinq équipes qui peuvent tout
autant la gagner que nous est-ce qu'on a
les armes pour oui après c'est les
matchs qui vont décider des tas de
formes du moment
et et les facteurs imprévus ou prévu le
hasard c'est peut-être ta chance ou la
malchance
je pense qu'on est l'équipe un peu moins
solide qu'en 2018 notamment en milieu de
terrain je regrette évidemment l'absence
en dehors de Pogba de Ngolo Kanté qui
était vraiment le note poumon en 2018 il
y a des facteurs chance il y a aussi un
facteur tableau on a un tableau qui est
sans faire offense aux autres équipes
qui vont finir première de leur groupe
un peu plus favorable c'est-à-dire qu'on
évite le Brésil et l'Argentine jusqu'en
finale donc c'est plutôt un bon signal
alors on va parler de ce qui s'est passé
en fin de match ce but d'Antoine
Griezmann marqué dans les toutes
dernières secondes on pensait le coup de
sifflet final donné puis finalement non
le but a été annulé voulait revenir
là-dessus David à Soline oui parce que
c'est très symbolique d'abord pas
finalement non il a bien été donné le
coup de sifflet final donc normalement
il y a dans les règlements aucun appel à
la barre possible à ce moment-là donc je
pense d'ailleurs que la Fédération
française fait un recours parce que ça
parce que ça c'est complètement établi
les règles au moins elles sont écrites
et il y a une plein de possibilités
c'est si un joueur après à insulter ou à
mentir sur son identité on peut revenir
mais le cas le jeu etc n'existe pas bon
donc ça c'est par mais sur le plan la
peau politique oui
j'étais surpris de voir comment
maintenant
l'argent le commerce donc la publicité
venait s'imposer sur l'événement qu'on
est essentiel diffuser
dès le coup de sifflet final on balance
une pub parce qu'on a un beaucoup de
monde captif et donc on doit vendre
l'écran de cette façon en disant c'est
l'écran le plus cher parce que tout le
monde est devant et c'est la c'est les
dernières secondes or quand on
prive
le téléspectateur celui qui regarde de
ce qui se passe pendant une minute après
enfin qu'on gagne ou qu'on perde il y a
des émotions sur le terrain il y a
quelque chose qui se passe et
ces coupures me choquait mais là hier
c'est venu
se montrer au monde comme une aberration
puisque c'est quelques secondes
effectivement dès que le coup de sifflet
final est fait TF1 a coupé tout de suite
mais n'a pas pu donc suivre ce qui était
quand même majeur le fait que bah un
match souhaite dix ans le résultat même
du match a été inversé sans que
le diffuseur
pas de coupure pub une minute avant le
coup d'envoi une minute après le coup
d'envoi ou plus longtemps parce qu'il y
a aussi une coupure pub entre les îles
et là avant il y avait pas de règle il y
avait juste le respect de lutter les
spectateur on a la charge de diffuser un
événement de porter mondiale et de
porter nationale importante donc on on a
une éthique de la chose c'est pas
possible par exemple quand une équipe
gagne et bien elle fait un tour il y a
des pleurs il y a des rires il y a des
gens et tu allais par terre il y a des
saluts tout ça c'est l'événement il y a
il y a des consolations des équipes
adverse qui veulent dire des choses
quand par exemple vous voyez le match
Iran États-Unis un joueur américain qui
consomme un joueur iranien qui pleure
sur son épaule c'est quelque chose qu'on
doit montrer on va pas dire non c'est la
pub le moitié fini donc il y en a marre
que
ce soit le commerce ce soit le le fric
je vais le dire comme ça qui viennent
polluer
le sport à la télévision et d'ailleurs
j'avais fait un rapport là-dessus et je
pense que il faudra y revenir
les images ça m'a choqué aussi que l'on
puisse couper instantanément la
diffusion de ce match ou de cette fin de
match
TF1 a fait en disant que les gens les
caméras étaient rentrés sur le terrain
enfin voilà visiblement le match était
terminé le coup de sifflet était donné
faut rappeler que le coup d'envoi après
le but le coup d'envoi a été donné et à
la suite de ce coup d'envoi le coût les
trois coups de sifflet signant la fin du
match d'après les règlements il n'y a
qu'un seul cas qui peut permettre de
revenir de refaire du jeu c'est un cas
d'exclusion donc une agression verbale
physique ou une insulte voilà ça n'était
pas le cas un jeu ne rentre pas donc il
y a une faute il y a une erreur
manifeste d'abord de de jugement de
l'arbitre je m'étonne et on recourt à
l'avare en croyant que l'arbitrage peut
être totalement automatisé totalement
aseptisé de de faux humaine d'erreur
humaine on voit bien que ça n'est pas le
cas que un arbitre qui va consulter une
Var prend une décision contre
dérèglement internationaux il y a une
contradiction maintenant sur l'aspect
freak de qu'évoque David à souligne on
peut pas d'un côté se plaindre que qui
est de moins en moins d'événements
internationaux qui soient diffusé en
clair sur nos chaînes c'est pas du
service public j'entends mais c'est
quand même en clair c'est un accès grand
public d'un événement majeur et TF1 je
crois a fait une Vésuve en excuser mais
pas leur projet de de d'immédiatement
optimisé leur diffusion parce que ça ça
coûte cher aussi les les tarifs de la
FIFA sont pas c'est pas des c'est pas
des philanthropes donc voilà on regrette
mais je comprends et encore une fois le
coup de sifflet final était donné je
comprends les émotions qui ne sont pas
retranscrites mais après si on va dans
ce sens là on va pas se on n'ira pas
pleurer lorsque tout sera diffusé sur
sur bein ou sur sur d'autres plateformes
payantes intégralement non mais quand
même une petite remarque non c'est c'est
justement ça vient de
ça n'a été possible que parce qu'il y a
ce genre de coupure qui n'existait pas
avant si brutal c'est-à-dire que bien
entendu qu'il faut de la publicité et
c'est pour ça que TF1 peut diffuser ou
sinon elle pourrait pas le diffuser donc
là-dessus on est complètement d'accord
mais on peut pas dire ces regrettable et
dire que ils ont bien fait non ils ont
mal fait puisque ça rend possible ce
genre de choses ça a été vraiment la
seconde
nous a montré ensuite TF1 c'est-à-dire
ces images où on voit bien les trois
coups de sifflet etc ils ont pas pu le
montrer c'est après ils nous l'ont
montré pour prouver leur bonne foi on
aurait pu le juger s'il n'avait pas
coupé bon donc franchement il ne faut
pas que que pour des histoires d'argent
on altère ni l'un c'est une information
l'information et la qualité des
programmes que l'on diffuse bien entendu
ça ne veut pas dire que il n'y a pas pas
besoin d'argent ou que je j'ignore cette
nécessité on va parler on va continuer à
parler sport on va parler des Jeux
Olympiques puisque hier vous étiez en
visite on est à 600 jours des Jeux
Olympiques un tout petit peu plus et
vous étiez en visite sur le chantier du
site du village olympique à Saint-Ouen
c'est la classe totalité des athlètes
seront hébergés Marion Delpech et Adrien
3500 ouvriers 37 grues et pas moins de
40 architectes d'ici mars 2024 ce
chantier pharaonique laissera place au
village des athlètes 15000 au total de
plus de 200 nationalités le géant
vasclos avant que le village ne soit
reconverti en véritable quartier de vie
on est au cœur du village olympique au
niveau de la future gare routière des
des Jeux Olympiques là où les athlètes
partiront pour leurs compétition et
derrière nous on voit la cité du cinéma
ce grand bâtiment en briques qui pendant
les Jeux servira de restaurant pour les
15000 athlètes accueillis dans le
village et derrière on voit les
bâtiments de logement qui s'élèvent sur
Saint-Ouen et sur Saint-Denis et qui
serviront donc du logement pendant les
jeux et qui après les Jeux accueilleront
6000 habitants et 6000 salariés
construit sur cette ancienne zone
industrielle de 52 hectares le site est
en concentré du savoir-faire français
dans le domaine de la construction à
l'international réduction d'empreintes
carbone lutte contre les îlots de
chaleur urbains signalét inclusive et
multi-sensorielle tout a été pensé pour
répondre aux enjeux environnementaux
cette délégation de sénateur est venue
son assurer sur le terrain après avoir
lancé une mission d'information à ce
titre nous nous sommes évidemment très
attentifs à la question financière de
voir de vérifier que nous restons dans
dans les purs de ce qui avait été
annoncé et puis différents aspects dont
au fur et à mesure au fil du temps on
voit qu'ils sont importants notamment la
question de la sécurité ce qui nous
importait aussi en venant plus
spécifiquement ici c'est de voir comment
la problématique environnementale qui
était à des aspects très mis en avant
dans la candidature française comment
elle se concrétisait à travers la
réalisation de ce village olympique le
quartier en construction dont la
superficie équivaut à 70 terrains de
football s'étendra sur trois communes
avec une ambition celui-ci à la hauteur
de l'événement Stéphane qui est dans
quels ont été vos impressions lors de la
vie de chantier l'ampleur du chantier
c'était dit 52 hectares en prise totale
donc c'est gigantesque c'est des
constructions des projets immobiliers
vraiment d'envergure et très ambitieux
et avec des architectures d'ailleurs à
noter et puis c'est une des travaux en
intégration c'est à dire qu'on moi ce
qui m'a épaté souvent quand on a ce
genre de construction on a un périmètre
qui est entièrement clos et on construit
l'intégralement à l'intérieur de ce
périmètre là il faut composer avec un
collège à côté avec des boîtes qui
continuent à tourner un musée et il faut
jongler avec ça la sécurité on l'a bien
entendu hier et vraiment un axe majeur
de la politique qui appliquait sur place
avec des rues qui sont vraiment
totalement fermées ce qui n'est pas sans
poser des problèmes de circulation et
aussi pour les familles et les enfants
qui doivent aller dans le collège on est
vraiment le collège et dans le périmètre
au plus près des constructions donc tout
ça c'est c'est épatant c'est
l'accélération aussi des choses parce
que on voit à la fois sur le plan
urbanistique puisque il aurait fallu
probablement 15 ans pour réaliser un tel
projet immobilier là ça va être réalisé
en 6 ans depuis l'acquisition la
première acquisition foncières et puis
c'est l'accélération aussi sur des sur
le côté vertueux et économe en carbone
après de 50% de gains de CO2 par rapport
aux normes 2019 c'est énorme ça veut
dire qu'on a utilisé de beaucoup de bois
du béton bas carbone aussi et on voit
que ce type de grands projets national
international accélère des politiques
publiques en fait on essaie de mettre en
oeuvre parfois par des lois de manière
un peu plus laborieuses
et puis il y a deux questions après je
vous repensais à la question c'est deux
inquiétudes est-ce que les délaisses
contenus est-ce que les coûts seront
respectés est-ce qu'il y a une
inquiétude sur le dépassement des coûts
de CGOS
bon première impression quand on est
là-bas c'est que
c'est beaucoup plus gigantesque ce qu'on
a pu imaginer il y a plus de grue
maintenant plus que le gros œuvre est
fait mais franchement
on est en même temps rassuré parce qu'on
se dit que
on est à temps c'est à dire que c'est
bien avancé il y a ce gigantisme et en
même temps on pourrait paniquer parce
que même pour un petit immeuble à Paris
l'aider les respecter je sais pas quand
ça existe dans ce pays donc sur un tel
chantier on peut mais là on n'a pas le
droit à l'erreur 31 décembre ça doit
être livré parce que on va pas reporter
les JO parce que c'est pas livré 2021
[Rires]
donc d'abord ça le fait j'étais aussi
impressionné par le gigantisme mais
aussi par le fait que on voit bien que
maintenant on est on est dans la
dernière phase et qu'on va être à temps
dans un an ensuite je j'ai aussi été
impressionné par la façon dont on a
conçu les choses et pour de façon
écologique c'est-à-dire les matériaux on
voit vous voyez le bois même quand il
était après recouvert des structures en
bois bon et ça faut faut le vouloir tout
un tas de recyclage de matériaux de
terre etc
et puis et puis le
on a pu voir concrètement comment ça va
être reconverti directement pour le
logement social et y compris des
logements en bureau quand il y a une
destination de bureau après avec
une possibilité
que le fer de façon facile aujourd'hui
si vous voulez convertir des bureaux en
logement ou l'inverse c'est il faut
quasiment tout recasser donc c'est du
gâchis à tous les niveaux
ça va être un quartier incroyable et
jamais vous avez raison jamais avec des
investissements normaux on aurait mis
ses délais ni ce quartier aurait pu
bénéficier de cette chance et en termes
d'équipement collectif de logements
sociaux et d'activité économique avec
les bureaux donc c'est c'est vraiment
pour l'instant beaucoup d'optimisme
après est-ce que
là aussi sur la question financière il
faut veiller
les choses avaient l'air maîtrisé à part
j'ai posé d'ailleurs la question hier
j'étais surpris que on est donné des
chiffres en 2017 sans tenir compte de
l'inflation courante je parle pas de
l'inflation exceptionnelle parce que
forcément ça trompe l'oeil donc déjà en
prenant l'inflation courante on est à
150 millions de de
déficit entre guillemets pas de déficit
dans tous les cas de dépassement des
prévisions et puis l'inflation
exceptionnelle qu'on pouvait pas prévoir
je le concède
ils évaluent à peu près à au même
chiffre voir un peu plus important donc
ça va faire un dépassement de 3 à 400
millions
et ça
on va en savoir plus mais l'État doit
prendre largement plus ça part quand il
dit deux tiers au collectivités locales
un tiers pour moi alors que déjà il
n'aide pas les collectivités locales
avec la crise énergétique avec
l'inflation et quels sont elles aussi à
l'os avec des factures qui explosent il
ne prend pas sa responsabilité et donc
j'espère que on ne va pas faire peser
sur les collectivités ce dépassement là
et que l'État va abonder plus vous
partagez cette inquiétude Stephen Kings
c'était le chiffre qui a été annoncé
très rapidement la
reconnu qu'on serait probablement
au-delà il faut savoir que le les
contrats ont été signés sur des euros
sur une sur des euros 2017 donc on
savait qu'il y avait de toute façon une
inflation il y avait un surcoût de même
qu'il y a des délais qui sont rarement
respectés dans dans la construction
immobilière il y a toujours un peu de un
peu d'excès d'excédent sur les sur les
dépenses je pense que ça va se tenir il
faut bien avoir en tête quand même qu'il
y a il y a un budget qui est maîtrisé ce
que ce que je reproche c'est un peu
cette division en deux entités vous
savez il y a le kojob et puis la solideo
qui est gros globalement en 4 milliards
de budget chacune ce qui fait un et on
commet chacune communique sur ce budget
là alors qu'en fait si on totalise ça
fait bien 8 milliards donc ça nous
rapproche des standards le Londres Tokyo
c'était 12 milliards 12 13 milliards à
chaque fois bon on est quand même bien
moins donc c'est quand même un des Jeux
Olympiques qui se veulent vertueux dans
dans la dépense publique je comprends
que Paris soit inquiet pour supporter
les surplus dans les mois prochain
et puis il y a il y a la
Seine-Saint-Denis qui a déjà
suffisamment de fardeau à assumer parce
que c'est un c'est c'est un des
départements les plus pauvres et qui
supportent le plus de pauvreté en France
et donc c'est normal que j'avertise tout
en pensant qu'il y a il y a quand même
une maîtrise il y a eu des dérapages
tellement fous dans l'organisation des
JO la Grèce le Brésil enfin bon euh
visiblement ça n'a pas une autre
inquiétude mais on n'est pas au bout
mais là maintenant que les que l'État
prenne ses responsabilités il y a une
autre inquiétude qui concerne les locaux
on va en parler avec vaudrait ils sont
remontés les élus locaux contre parce
que l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques
ça pourrait causer l'annulation de
nombreux festivals oui on pense
notamment aux Solidays à Rock en scène
Lola paloza les Vieilles Charrues j'en
cite que quelques-uns mais des festivals
et des événements sportifs il y en a
pléthore quand on part du 23 juin départ
de la flamme au 8 septembre fin des Jeux
paralympiques le problème c'est qu'avec
800 000 voire 700 000 personnes rien que
pour la cérémonie d'ouverture qui se
déroulera en plein air il va falloir une
hyper présence des policiers et des
gendarmes dans un contexte de risque
terroristes c'est ce que dit Gérald de
Darmanin le ministre de l'intérieur on
parle même de faire venir des militaires
réservistes tout cela au détriment des
autres collectivités qui accueillent des
événements qui ne sont pas liés au jeu
il y aura moins de force de sécurité
disponibles le ministre de l'Intérieur
évoque même la possibilité de déplacer
voire d'annuler certains événements pour
vous donner une idée le Tour de France
qui est quand même une institution voit
son départ décalé en raison des Jeux
Olympiques alors les élus montent au
créneau évidemment parce qu'on parle de
dizaines de millions d'euros
d'investissement de de d'argent récoltés
de d'emploi et donc la semaine dernière
c'est David Lisnard le président des
maires de France qui s'en est emparés il
a transmis un message à la première
ministre dans son discours à la MF
écouter
je crois qu'il serait très mauvais pour
l'image même des JO mais surtout très
mauvais pour notre pays que les
festivals les animations d'été les
grandes rencontres soit annulées décalés
perturbé réduite à cause de ce qui
serait vécu comme les Jeux Olympiques
[Applaudissements]
je sais que
des travaux ont été engagés en la
matière
[Applaudissements]
mais ces événements et notamment nous
événements culturels bien évidemment
permettre le partage de la culture bien
évidemment sont très souvent des centres
de ressources de création de richesse de
création de valeur de création d'emplois
et surtout marque tellement l'image de
la France les grands festivals d'été
sont la France font la France et la font
rayonner dans le monde entier
vous le voyez David lisner qui a été
très applaudi en par les élus et la
première ministre lui a répondu dans son
discours qui suivait écouté
et meuf nous examinerons le calendrier
et construirons une solution équilibrée
un travail a été initié par les
ministres de l'intérieur des sports et
de la culture pour trouver les
ajustements nécessaires il va se
poursuivre jusqu'à la fin du mois en
lien avec les mers les organisateurs et
les préfets
accueillir les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques c'est un défi considérable
en termes de sécurité c'est un défi
considérable pour nos forces de sécurité
intérieure et nous devons être au
rendez-vous
Isabelle bande qui a donc prôné la
conciliation mi-décembre elle doit faire
un point avec les festivals le sort de
ces mêmes festivals sera abordé le 18
décembre lors d'une réunion du conseil
d'administration des JO ouais
est-ce que vous êtes rassuré parce qu'a
dit Elizabeth borne pas du tout façon
c'est quand même dingue de voir qu'on
consulte maintenant sur des décisions
qui ont été prises par le Président de
la République avec une cérémonie
d'ouverture tout en mégalomanie pour
pour Jupiter avec deux fois 6 km à
couvrir avec des forces de l'ordre qui
sont déjà très sollicitées je rappelle
qu'on est toujours en très grande
vigilance attentat sur notre sur notre
territoire on dit tiens c'est une idée
géniale et puis on a le ministre de
l'intérieur du coup qui lors d'une
audition dit on va annuler tous les
festivals et et elle a mis descente 2022
on va dire on va se concerter pour voir
quel festival on pourrait maintenir en
2024 mais tout est quasiment calé
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que les un
festival ça s'organise pas sur deux ou
trois mois c'est c'est il faut prendre
date avec les avec les artistes etc
enfin je comprends pas la méthode qui
qui est une problématique sur
l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques avec
une concentration de force de sécurité
je l'entends mais la méthode elle est
quand même très contestable
oui d'abord c'est pas la faute à la
beauté de la cérémonie envisagée parce
que ça c'est je suis très heureux que ça
va que ce soit magnifique et que le
monde voit quelque chose de magnifique
la scène le patrimoine et vous allez
voir les retombées économiques pour le
tourisme de de de faire les choses un
beau et en grand donc le problème n'est
pas là c'est que le ministre de
l'Intérieur oppose le sport à la culture
et justement c'est le moment où la
France montre au monde donc si tout ce
qui fait qu'elle brille et qui et qui
est au fond très fond de la meuf
française de sa créativité etc quelle
est la culture on la met de côté que
symboliquement y compris c'est
complètement fou économiquement ce
pianoara a raison les festivals tout ce
programme bien avant et même à décalage
de trois jours ça change tout et ça fait
perdre de l'argent mais surtout je je
trouve fou que il y a un problème de
sécurité
mais il y a l'armée elle peut faire des
tâches de protection civile on peut très
bien
par l'ensemble de ces ministères il y a
pas que le ministère d'intérieur pour
faire qu'il y ait des forces un nombre
suffisant et je pense que si Monsieur
Darmanin qui aurait dû avoir cette idée
tout seul quand même il a pas besoin de
moi de la part c'est probablement parce
que il y a une question de je veux être
le patron et il peut pas être le patron
de l'armée donc il faut savoir
collaborer et l'État c'est
avec tous ces moyens
[Musique]